[Music]
foreign
hello and welcome to what's new for
application Developers
I'm Thomas demaio and we're thrilled to
have you here we're so excited about
what the future holds and we've invested
a lot to make you successful with Google
Cloud so you can build applications
faster and more secure than ever
you may have heard Thomas kurian talk
about how we offer prescriptive Guidance
with an opinionated approach to solve
developer velocity challenges in today's
session I'm going to show you how
exactly we do this by highlighting how
Google Cloud lets you deliver secure
applications in an open manner driving
developer velocity is especially
important given there continues to be a
global shortage of developers in fact
the global shortage of full-time
developers will increase from today's
1.4 million to over 4 million in 2025.
so we want to make every moment count to
be as fast and productive as possible to
help alleviate this developer shortage
last year we announced a goal to equip
40 million people with Cloud skills over
the next five years
today
we're taking that to the next level with
our enhanced Google Cloud skills boost
with innovators Plus
this annual subscription provides access
to training special events Google Cloud
credits and expanded developer benefits
all for 299 US dollars per year
even though working remotely has become
the norm working faster remotely and
across distributed teams continues to be
a challenge typical friction points
include onboarding route employees
setting up Dev and test environments and
long build times just to name a few
when it comes to security code and data
exfiltration risks are key
this is especially true in sensitive and
regulated environments
customers tell us that current solutions
to secure Dev environments can add
developer friction to the experience
for example streaming-based Solutions
May introduce unwanted latency
in running your specific containers may
not be fully supported
solving developer velocity challenges
requires a two-pronged approach
how do we not only make it easier for
developers to build applications but
also easy for it admins to securely
scale in Dev environments
to address this
I'm excited to announce the availability
of cloud workstations
think of cloud workstations as providing
pre-configured but customizable
developer environments in the cloud with
your favorite dev tools pre-installed
and up to date
Cloud workstations come with multi-ide
support such as IntelliJ pycharm Ryder
sea lion Koto SS and others as part of
this fully managed experience and since
Cloud workstations can run inside the
same network as your other resources you
don't need to emulate services or
databases which Can Save hours by
developing and running code in your
staging environment Cloud workstations
enables consistent developer definitions
among developers with all environments
defined via containers
fixing the well it works on my machine
problem
you can also access your favorite devops
tooling including third-party tools such
as git lab teamcity Jenkins to build
test and deploy quickly as part of your
end-to-end workflow even if they're
self-hosted on-prem or in other clouds
from an admins perspective Cloud
workstations can dramatically simplify
the onboarding of new developers at
scale
you can create a workstation
configuration
which defines a shared template of the
tools developers need including VM type
IDE extensions libraries code samples
and environment settings
increasing developer velocity is
incomplete without having the right
security controls in place for remote
Developers
this is why Cloud workstations has
Enterprise grade security requirements
built right in
this starts with VPC service controls
where you can limit developer access to
sensitive areas you can update or patch
your environments so that developers get
the most up-to-date version
and you can also use a fully private
Gateway so that only trusted users
within your network have Dev access
next up Christian Gorka head of the
Cyber Center of Excellence at Commerce
Bank tells us how Cloud workstations is
driving remote developer velocity while
maintaining the bank security needs
thank you Thomas comments bank is the
leading bank for the show in
mitchelstand and a strong partner for
around 28 000 corporate client groups
and around 11 million private and small
business customers in Germany while
being present internationally in almost
40 countries
Comet bank is increasingly using Cloud
technology to bring new products and
customer experiences faster to the
market leveraging modern technology and
optimizing system performance as well as
running costs and sustainability
for many organizations developer
productivity and in particular for US
security are top of mind and a first
class priority
because of the nature of our business
that is being part of a strictly
regulated industry our developers handle
a lot of very sensitive applications
to enable development in a safe
environment we have an extensive list of
security and compliance controls that
need to be checked off before we can
adopt the solution
I'm excited about Cloud workstations
because it helps us take care of many
items on that list for example it lets
us integrate our development environment
into our virtual private Cloud behind
VPC service controls so that we can make
sure our source code and intellectual
property do not leave our virtual
premises furthermore it supports
customer managed encryption Keys as well
as data recognization making sure data
confidentiality and geolocation is under
our control
and while Cloud workstations comes with
pre-installed software many things still
are configurable
plus we can easily patch vulnerabilities
and update OS images across various
teams in a central place which not only
saves us time but also helps improves
overall security posture
finally our developers really like the
speed and responsiveness of the cloud
workstations provides
onboarding can be done within minutes
and the service is easily accessible
from anywhere of course access granted
so in the end we are in need of
something that works out of the box is
fully managed and integratable into
Google Cloud ecosystem and its services
hence I'm glad that we now can leverage
Cloud workstations back to you Thomas
thanks Christian it was great to hear
how developers at Commerce Bank can
securely collaborate across the world
Cloud workstations can provide security
capabilities as you code which can be
extended to other parts of your software
supply chain from build dependency
management to deployment
recent attacks such as log 4J solarwinds
and mimecast have showcased the
importance of ensuring security across
your software supply chain beyond the
coding environment
in fact the White House is now requiring
all federal suppliers to conform to
software security standards across their
supply chain
in the EU Agency for cyber security has
recognized this threat as well
to further complicate things the
extensive use of Open Source and their
dependencies makes this a challenging
problem to solve
to help Google pledge 100 million
dollars last year to support third-party
foundations like openssf that manage
open source security priorities and help
fix vulnerabilities
we've also pledged to help one hundred
thousand Americans earn Google career
certificates to learn skills including
data privacy and security
on the product side we are taking those
efforts to the next level with the
launch of software delivery Shield
software delivery Shield provides a
fully managed end-to-end software supply
chain security
this starts with the IDE and includes CI
CD pipelines deploy time policies and
runtime security posture
so while you're focused on writing code
software delivery Shield or SDS is
helping to make sure your organization's
security policy is consistently enforced
across the software delivery process
enabling you to develop faster
specifically SDS adds new security
capabilities in four major areas
first to shift left into the IDE we are
launching Cloud code Source protect
a private preview IDE extension which
helps you better understand open source
vulnerabilities and licenses to go
faster by avoiding costly and
frustrating rework down the road
second when it comes to securing
dependencies we're excited to announce
our assured open source software service
it scans for known vulnerabilities
analyze and fuzz tests over 250 packages
across Java and python
these packages are built using Google
secured pipelines to help external
dependency risks and come with
remediation slas
third
SDS helps secure CI CD with Cloud build
which now supports salsa level 3.
for those unfamiliar salsa is an
emerging standard that incorporates best
practices for software supply chain
integrity
Cloud build provides verifiable build
provenance to help you trace a binary to
its source and build process to prevent
tampering improve the artifact you're
using is legit
fun fact Providence is not just
available for containers but for Java
Maven packages as well
lastly SDS can extend security
protection into Cloud run and gke
Cloud run security panel now includes
software supply chain security insights
this provides information such as salsa
level on the running container images
build provenance and service
vulnerabilities
to help protect kubernetes workloads gke
security posture management provides
opinionated foundational guidance into
your gke clusters
we do this by providing detailed
security assessments actionable
remediation advice and scanning for OS
vulnerabilities in your running images
we're integrating the platform to
further help drive speed and efficiency
for instance
Cloud deploy can make continuous
delivery for cloud run much simpler
promote from pre-prod to prod conduct
rollbacks and manage gate promotion
approvals in a cohesive and intuitive
interface
with the new Cloud run Integrations you
can connect Cloud run with Google cloud
services fast
for example configuring domains with a
load balancer or connecting to a redis
cache is now as easy as a single click
and by the way we have more scenarios on
the way
with these enhancements you no longer
need to be an expert in scaling securing
or managing your pipelines or connecting
to other Google cloud services
everything we discussed from cloud
workstations software delivery shield
and Cloud run enhancements are designed
to help developer velocity and we do
this in an open fashion in fact we
continually evaluate the developer
experience across Google cloud and have
a dedicated team making ongoing
improvements to reduce developer
friction and make things faster
at Google we're big proponents of Open
Source and Open Standards as the number
one contributor to the cncf open source
projects our goal has been openness
wherever possible
with that I'm excited to announce that
Google has joined the eclipse adoptium
working group
a Consortium of leaders in the Java
Community working to establish a higher
quality developer-centric standard for
Java distributions
as a strategic member of adoptium Google
will promote Open Standards that benefit
all developers everywhere regardless of
where they run their workloads
and that starts by making Eclipse
Tamarin available across Google Cloud
products and services
Eclipse Tamarin provides Java developers
a higher quality developer experience
and more opportunities to create
integrated Enterprise focused Solutions
with the openness they deserve
next up Victor Salve from the product
team discusses a simplified and secure
Java developer experience
thanks Thomas and hey everyone my name
is Victor Salve I'm a product manager
here at Google Cloud focused on supply
chain security we're going to be taking
a look at all the components Thomas just
outlined collectively known as software
delivery Shield
so let's get started with the demo
Cloud workstations provides my team with
Project Specific profiles configured
with the memory CPU
and the tools required such as the IDE
today we're going to be looking at a
Java Maven project so we'll launch a
Java Dev environment and get started
with our Maven work
to shift left on security Cloud code now
provides dependency insights right in
the IDE including vulnerabilities in
direct and transitive dependencies
upper delivery Shield also has
trust-based policy gating in this case I
have a policy in place requiring that
deployed images be built by Cloud build
and conformed to a vulnerability
threshold So Random images like this one
are blocked
so let's use cloud code to find and fix
all of our vulnerable dependencies so
that our policy thresholds are satisfied
I can now trigger a cicd process using
Cloud bill
my build has succeeded and my image was
successfully deployed
Cloud build now provides security
insights into the built artifacts like
this container image providing me
information about the salsa level of the
build
any vulnerabilities lurking in the build
as well as a list of dependencies
and the provenance of the build
well I hope that demo gave you a sense
for software delivery Shield back to you
Thomas
thanks Victor in addition to what we've
covered we've also been focused on
helping remove barriers across our data
platform allowing developers to build
data-driven applications faster
after all data often Powers the most
impactful experiences for example
with Google services such as Cloud
firestore we're making it easy to infuse
Ai and ml across data-driven workflows
to help build Rich end-to-end
data-centric applications
in fact over 4 million databases have
been created in firestore to power
mobile and web applications
we're providing integration with vertex
AI our AIML platform
this enables inferencing directly within
the database transaction
in addition we're announcing in preview
spanner integration with vertex AI
this integration allows data scientists
to build their models easily in vertex
AI and developers to access those models
using the SQL query language
we also understand that data can reside
in third-party databases too
and developers still want those
experiences to be fast and easy to
deploy
so when working with data Centric
third-party Stacks such as the mean
stack
JavaScript developers can quickly deploy
mongodb Atlas and Cloud run our
serverless compute solution
with Google provided terraform Scripts
read our related blog post to find the
repo where you can grab this and other
texts will soon follow
it's a great time to be a developer
because software is enabling businesses
to re-imagine how they're providing more
engaging experiences
in doing this with the peace of mind
that security is embedded at every step
of the way and everything I just
described was designed to help you focus
on what you love writing code fast
we're excited to create this future
together thanks for joining us
[Music]